because like what i feel like the
biggest difference between the manga and
the anime adaptation for me
was that the anime is just missing this
intensity that
i kind of felt when reading the manga
and i'm pretty sure it's just because
when you're reading manga
you know because of the art you can kind
of like you can kind of just you
you feel this intensity because like
you're filling in the gaps with your
mind
right that and that's that's how reading
manga works for me at least with anime
you don't you know it's presented right
in front of you because the movement is
there
right and that's that's why to me like
imagine if one punch man season one
got the same adaptation as season two
right
what part of the big appeal of one punch
man the manga at least is the art is
[ __ ] incredible right yeah and i feel
like just because
you see the difference between season
one and season two and just because
season two just feels
so much more flat compared to the manga
and that's just because
the story's there you've got the same
story but just the intensity of the art
impact the intensity even though it was
it was disappointing yeah um i still
love season two with one punch fun
i i really enjoyed it honestly i love
one punch man man it's one of my
favorite manga and shows of all time
like i mean i get
i don't know how you can watch season
one
and being like that was [ __ ]
incredible and then watch you know a
show that was
he's half as good as season one of trash
taste we find out connor doesn't have
ears
season two of trash taste we find out
conor doesn't have eyes no i'm not
saying
i'm not saying sonny it's a [ __ ] hell
no i'm not saying that one punch man
season two is not a downgrade it is it's
still a banger show though it's still
great
like one punch man for me although the
action was
amazing it was like it was like the
amazing tiramisu after your five course
meal you know the animation right
to me it was always it was always the
story in one punch man
like because it seems like it doesn't
have it but then season two they
introduced garu
gaoru oh my god i love that
it's such a good good aspect in the
story i love how it plays into it and
then the manga now is amazing like i
[ __ ] love reading i mean i don't
think the story i mean this this this is
going to one hot take to another
right honestly i don't think the story
should i don't want to love god do it
just [ __ ] on what i love
i don't know i don't think the story of
one punch man is like top tier
i think it's a good story but like if
you get if you're gonna talk about story
from one
i mean [ __ ] mob psycho 100 i think
has a way better story than one punch
map i i
have to agree with that like what yeah
and mob's more of a neater story
everything wraps up nicely
everything it just feel it just feels
like it's more of a story and i'm not
saying one punch man doesn't have a
story obviously i think
it has a pretty decent story i would
rank mob higher than one punch man yeah
but by far
by far mob to me is the full package not
by far calm down right
come on one mob psycho is like pretty
much
the full package on everything you want
it's got a great animation uh it's got a
very good story very well written
characters and i feel like one punch man
one punch man just kind of rolled off a
gimmick
like i i like they use that they turned
a gimmick
into a lovable story into a lovable
story which i feel
couldn't sustain itself i don't know i
disagree i think the story
right now is amazing i'm not saying this
story is bad you're [ __ ] in one punch
man i think it's great
but i think one mob psycho definitely
had a better self but mob psycho is
finished yeah and one punch man's still
going scientists
check that
bigger length equals better wait no i
mean don't admit one piece is good
no i don't know i i i don't know i
although i agree that mob psycho 100 is
probably the strongest story there's
something about
one punch man season two that really
gets gets me i don't know it gets me
killed it gets me going it's just your
personal preference right yes sir
you're entitled to your wrong opinion
yeah i mean for me season two was it was
okay
it was it was okay yeah it was great i
mean season two for me was just like all
right like
even in the manga i feel like that arc
that season two adapted was
one of the lesser exciting parts of the
story
i feel like the real good part of the
story is what it's called
literally the arc after that's when the
story starts getting interesting but
i mean there's like the issue is that
you got to deal with saitama
as as a you know as a story element and
i feel like he just hasn't or there
hasn't been like the right way to like
deal with it because i feel like
the most interesting part of one punch
man season two and season three is garo
and i feel like that was the element
that he added to try to save that but
saitama is still there and there's only
so much you can play off that
season three i'm i'm saying if season
three did get adapted yeah we haven't
heard
anything about that have we no it got
did it get announced no i don't think so
no
did mob psycho season three get
announced i don't think there's enough
for season three is there there's
from what i understand there's not that
much left of mob psycho
i don't know i i i didn't finish mobster
i don't know but what
how did you not finish it because he's
the anime man because i just had
not enough time because i was reading
other because i was reading other things
bro what